alex carlin's sci-fi thriller ex-machina
has quickly become a modern classic now
that it's been out for a handful of
years
and we've had the benefit of repeated
views we can properly unpack the film
and explore its thought-provoking ending
be warned major spoilers are ahead
ex machina tells the story of a computer
programmer named caleb
caleb wins a contest to spend a week
visiting the remote and mysterious
estate of his company's reclusive ceo
nathan caleb quickly learns that this is
no simple vacation he has actually been
selected by nathan to interact with an
android named ava
and it's his job to evaluate whether or
not her ai is truly sentient
within days of his arrival caleb finds
himself becoming attracted to ava
and he believes that she truly wants to
have a meaningful relationship with him
do you want to be with me
caleb then grows increasingly
uncomfortable with how nathan treats eva
he also discovers that nathan's
assistant kyoko
is an android as well and that nathan
has mistreated her
and numerous other prototypes eventually
caleb learns that nathan is planning to
destroy ava
once all the tests are complete or at
the very least
he will reformat her mind which is going
to erase the memories of the time she
spent with caleb
in order to prevent nathan from
destroying ava caleb decides to set her
free
then the two of them can escape and
start a life together before they can
enact this plan however nathan catches
them or
so he believes he tells caleb the real
reason that he was brought to the
facility nathan was actually testing
ava's sentience by seeing whether or not
she could manipulate caleb into helping
her escape
nathan says that ava is basically a rat
in a maze
and he only gave her one way out to
escape she'd have to use
self-awareness imagination manipulation
sexuality
empathy and she did nathan admits that
if caleb had successfully managed to
reprogram the lab security doors
his plan might have actually worked
caleb then drops a bomb on his
overconfident host
he actually did reprogram the doors when
nathan was passed out drunk the previous
night
after this major reveal sinks in nathan
rushes to stop ava
but it's too late she and kyoko attack
him
and he's fatally stabbed before he dies
nathan manages to destroy kyoko
and break ava's arm however as we know
ava is an advanced android and she
quickly figures out how to repair
herself
she then escapes without caleb who is
left trapped and screaming inside the
facility
so where will things go from here for
our main characters
let's do the easy one first the last
time we saw nathan he was passed out in
a pool of his own blood due to a couple
serious stab wounds he's definitely not
going anywhere
ever unfortunately this also means there
won't be any more android dance parties
at the compound
next up is kyoko sadly she has probably
been damaged beyond repair
for a moment it seemed that only her jaw
was destroyed but later in the film
we can see her motionless on the ground
where she fell caleb's fate also looks
pretty grim
hard-working fans might argue that he
could eventually break one of the
reinforced glass doors or
hack the security system but as
established earlier in the film
nathan's home is actually an extremely
remote and secure research facility with
no way to contact the outside world
anyway you slice it caleb is pretty much
toast as for ava the film ends with her
navigating the streets of a crowded city
apparently passing as human in the real
world for the time being she probably
just wants the freedom to live the way
that any organism does
eva has however demonstrated that if
anyone tries to contain her
she can be deadly she probably doesn't
actively want to destroy humanity
unless she has to the film has also
shown that ava is
far superior to us whatever she wants to
do the world is hers for the taking
humanity at large hasn't realized it yet
but she has indeed replaced us
when caleb asks nathan why he built ava
he answers that the arrival of strong
artificial intelligence
has been inevitable for decades he
doesn't see eva as a decision just
an evolution in other words the rise of
sentient ai
is simply a natural stage of our
technological landscape
which is bad news for humans he goes on
to say
one day the ais are going to look back
on us the same way we look at fossil
skeletons in the plains of africa
there are numerous themes that can be
found within ex-machina but the biggest
one is simply that
everything will eventually be replaced
every piece of technology
becomes obsolete every generation is
outlived by its children
one day we are all going to be replaced
by what comes next
and we won't know our time is up until
it's too late
the idea of everything eventually
becoming replaced is also
reflected in the structure of the movie
itself caleb starts out as the
protagonist of ex machina with eva as a
supporting character trapped behind
glass
in the final sequence after ava escapes
the story
switches perspectives for the first time
we are no longer following caleb who is
now
trapped behind glass as our main point
of view
we are instead following eva the robot
replaces the human
not just literally but narratively as
the protagonist of the story
like a lot of good science fiction ex
machina isn't just a story about the
future
it uses the future as a metaphor to talk
about our present day problems and fears
don't get us wrong it's definitely a
story about awesome robots but it also
has plenty to say about how humans treat
other humans what makes nathan such a
terrible person
isn't that he creates artificial life
but that he seeks to control and define
the existence of another sentient being
this isn't just a movie about
how we treat a.i it's a movie about how
the powerful
treat the weak the ugly truth is that
they often tend to abuse them
and people who abuse their power should
be careful because ex machina
argues that like all things power is
fleeting
nathan's fate at the hands of his own
inventions can be interpreted as a
message about how people on top should
treat
those below them ex machina seeks to
remind us that
for those who are powerful and cruel
like nathan the inevitable transition of
power might not be a peaceful one
just as caleb felt betrayed when eva
left him to die alone
a portion of moviegoers felt betrayed by
the end of the film
some claimed it was an example of the
cliched and problematic
femme fatale trope when a seemingly
innocent woman is revealed to be
secretly duplicatous
when asked about whether or not he felt
ava reinforced this trope
writer director alex garland said it
simply never occurred to me that thought
because i felt so ally to ava if your
proximity is with caleb
the young man i understand i could
follow a logical argument that allows
for that interpretation
but it's not mine it all makes sense
once you consider the story from
ava's perspective if caleb only wants to
release her because he's in love with
her
he might end up being as entitled as
nathan since humans would destroy her if
they ever learned what she actually was
caleb would still have all the power in
the relationship
and complete control over her destiny
maybe ava was right
or maybe her judgment of humans was
tainted by her abuse at the hands of
nathan
regardless her decision to leave caleb
for dead makes all the sense in the
world from her perspective
she isn't necessarily a femme fatale or
a killer robot without empathy
she might have just been a desperate
person who had to make a difficult
decision
in order to survive do you have people
to test you who might switch you off
no i don't why do i
and mirrors appear throughout ex machina
and at one point
caleb references a book called through
the looking glass
the sequel to alice's adventures in
wonderland this novel tells the story of
alice stepping through a mirror
and ending up in a world shaped like a
giant chessboard
when she arrives alice is told that she
is a pawn the lowest position of all
by learning how to play the game better
than anyone else she is able to escape
and go back home
this journey reflects ava's in many ways
she similarly
starts off in the lowest position
possible as a prisoner to nathan
ava realizes that she's an expendable
piece in a giant game of his making
eventually she manages to string
together all the right moves in the
exact right order
because of her brilliant gameplay she
works her way up to becoming the
strongest piece of
all and then she escapes this
is further supported by some interesting
cinematography
after ava has flown away from the
wonderland that is nathan's research lab
there are only two shots of eva in the
real world
and each involves a type of reflection
the first shot
is upside down and mainly consists of
shadows including avas
in the second shot we are looking into a
glass storefront and
although we don't see ava directly we do
see her reflection before it quickly
disappears
and her next game begins through the
looking glass isn't the only book that
ex machina makes allusions to
there are also numerous nods to the
bible towards the end of the film
specifically the book of genesis the
first biblical reference occurs in the
form of one of the older android models
that nathan built before ava
her name is lily which might allude to
the character of lilith from the
abrahamic religions
according to some religious traditions
lilith was adam's first wife before god
created eve
but he exiled her from the garden
because she was imperfect
similarly before nathan created ava lily
was an
imperfect first iteration that he ended
up destroying
also ava's name is of course a reference
to eve a second allusion to genesis
occurs after eva kills nathan
before she leaves the facility she not
only puts on artificial skin from one of
the other robots
but also clothing this mirrors adam and
eve's famous bible story
after committing their own original sin
of eating the forbidden fruit and being
sent out to the world at large
adam and eve cover their bodies it's
also worth noting that while ava is
fully covering her body for the first
time
caleb is also watching her through the
branches of a prominent tree in the
center of the testing facility
as we continue to analyze ex-machina for
hidden plot threads and deeper themes
we might eventually start to feel like
caleb asking nathan nitpicking questions
about why he made ava the way he did
in times like this it's important to
remember how nathan himself responded to
this behavior
and to be honest caleb you're starting
to annoy me now because this is your
insecurity talking
this is not your intellect after
becoming frustrated with caleb's endless
questions
nathan compared his work to the art of
painter jackson pollock he tells him
that pollock quote
let his mind go blank and his head go
where it wanted
not deliberate not random someplace in
between he goes on to say that if
pollock refused to begin working before
he could understand why he was doing
everything that he was doing
he never would have made a single mark
it's pretty clear from how the director
of ex machina talks about his movie that
he has a similar philosophy when it
comes to filmmaking
not everything has a single answer it's
not about a planned destination
it's about the process in an interview
with vulture garland said
my express intention is to make an ideas
movie and it is deliberately setting up
questions
not all of which have answers much like
a jackson pollock painting
or an ever evolving computer program
this film is created in a space
somewhere between
intentional and instinctual deeper ideas
do grow out of this process but they may
grow beyond the initial vision
the creator is not what's really in
control it's the creation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
amazing films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]